depuis son retrait du protocole de kyoto
en 2011 le canada fait figure de mauvais
élève sur la scène internationale et
pourtant il pourrait en être tout
autrement
selon un groupe de scientifiques qui
propose un véritable plan d'action pour
agir sur le climat on sort chantal sa
cellule après avoir sonné l'alarmé
scientifiques elles sont plutôt en mode
solution et vous savez la beauté de la
chose c'est que les citoyens les gens
qui nous regardent sont invités à leur
faire part de leurs suggestions
alors cette initiative qu'on doit un
groupe qui s'appelle dialogue pour un
canada vert ça c'est un regroupement de
plus d'une soixantaine de scientifiques
qui proviennent des universités partout
au canada et qui font partie de
discipline allant de la biologie à
l'économie à l'écologie au droit et j'en
passe ils se sont réunis à l'initiative
d'une biologiste catherine pots-de-vin
qui est professeur à l'université mcgill
quittent une spécialiste de la forêt
tropicale qui a été une négociatrice
pour le panama au grande conférence sur
le climat
elle connaît donc bien les enjeux de
part et d'autre et est là avec ses
collègues pondu ce document qui a été
lancé à montréal s'appelle agir sur les
changements climatiques des solutions
d'universitaires canadiens et
canadiennes
alors concrètement de quoi s'agit-il
quelles sont ces solutions plusieurs
choses tout d'abord bien sûr le fameux
carbone donner une valeur au carbone
c'est essentiel selon nous mais de plus
ils profitent vraiment de leur bagage de
connaissances scientifiques pour
élaborer une véritable feuille de route
pour que le canada puisse profiter des
avantages est vraiment tirer profit et
faire sa part également pour réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre alors
il entrevoit la possibilité réelle qu'on
ait réduit de 80% ici au canada
les émissions en 2050 la clé de voûte
c'est 100 % d'électricité faible en
carbone en 2035
salah énorme comme ça je vous le concède
mais ils ont vraiment fouiller la
littérature pour arriver à être dessinée
une très belle carte qu'on voit
présentement alors cette carte c'est la
carte du potentiel d'énergie
renouvelable du canada on voit en verre
sur les côtes à l'est et à l'ouest le
potentiel de l'éolien au centre dans les
prairies en jaune on voit le potentiel
de l'énergie solaire dans les prairies
dans le centre du canada il ya les
barrages qui sont ces petits points
blancs ce qui existe déjà en rose
on voit ce qui pourrait exister et tout
ça reliés par un réseau de transport
d'électricité faible en carbone parce
que leur souhait ultime c'est qu'on
n'est pas le canada a traversé par des
pipelines mais plutôt par des réseaux de
transport d'électricité fait d'énergies
renouvelables alors ça rend tout ça très
concrets sont intéressants et en
terminant les citoyens qui le désirent
vous en parlais au début peuvent
justement faire leurs suggestions
s'impliquer dans ce projet là en
personne demain soir 6 mai à montréal au
coeur des sciences de l'université du
québec à montréal pour une séance de
consultation publique en compagnie de
certains des scientifiques qui ont écrit
ce document et pour ceux qui n'ont pas
la chance d'être là ils ne sont pas en
reste puisque l'association francophone
pour le savoir acfas un site dédié où on
peut aller consulter le document d'une
soixantaine de pages
on peut aussi faire des suggestions et
donner ses commentaires il faut savoir
que en parallèle les scientifiques rend
compte également les politiciens on l'a
fait à québec on a fait à ottawa
on espère rencontrer ceux qui vont
représenter le canada lors de la grande
conférence à paris sur le climat à la
fin de l'année très bien c'est
intéressant pour une fois les gens
peuvent s'impliquer mois une solution
aussi un peu positif ça fait de percer
vont taper la balle mais oui ça fait du
bien